[Musique]
info intox et avec anthony st léger
bonjour en tenons au genre et on
s'intéresse à cette résurgence de
violences récentes entre le rwanda et la
république démocratique du congo elle a
ravivé les les anciennes tensions entre
les deux voisins contexte propice à la
diffusion de fausses informations
antonin effectivement en deux mots de
contact assez a brièvement on se situe
dans l'est de la rd congo on va voir ça
ensemble dans le nord-kivu frontalier du
rwanda cette zone elle est ici le rwanda
s est ici et c'est dans cette zone que
la rébellion du m23 le mouvement du 23
mars qui a été défait il ya une dizaine
d'années maintenant a repris les armes
c'est là aussi qu'on lieu des
affrontements sporadiques entre l'armée
congolaise et ce mouvement des violents
combats qui encore ont eu lieu fin mai
mouvement du m23 que kigali accuse
soutiendrait en tout cas c'est ce
qu'elle sait l'accusation portée par à
kinshasa notamment par la voix de son
président à phoenix est tshisekedi qui
l'a encore rappelé hier dimanche ce que
dément le rwanda mais la première un peu
que des militaires ont des tombées en
rdc effectivement via ce type de
publication a regardé cet internaute qui
présente ses condoléances aux familles
des soldats rwandais tomber en rdc des
mini des militaires rwandais qui serait
donc qu aurait donc été envoyés
combattre en rdc c'est la thèse donc
d'une agression rwandaise volontaire sur
kinshasa et pour appuyer à ces propos
vous voyez différentes photos et bien là
on est dans un exemple assez classique
de décontextualisation que l'on va
découvrir grâce à l'art fameuse
recherche d'image inversée en
l'occurrence via le moteur de recherche
russe yandex pourquoi celui-ci parce que
tout simplement de meilleurs résultats
quels sont les occurrences justement
plusieurs articles de presse dont celui
ci de south african avec plusieurs
indices d'abord une date
2019 et lorsque l'on parcourt le
l'article on retrouve la légende de la
photo est un nom de photographes
yasuyoshi chiba de la fp direction donc
la banque d'image de la fp et regardez
on retrouve effectivement le cliché en
question qui a été réalisée le 4 mai
2019 on est au rwanda au mémorial de
nyanza il s'agit d'une cérémonie pendant
laquelle le 81 cercueils ont été
enterrés pour honorer les victimes du
génocide de 1994
quant aux autres images on retrouve
trois des clichés de la publication
virale également via cette banque
d'image via ce photographe pour ce qui
est revenu sur la publication de cette
femme en pleurs ici la publication
virale là aussi la recherche d'image
inversée là aussi on est au rwanda en
2014 en l'occurrence et cette photo on
la doit à ce non pas à la fp cette fois
mais à elpy c'est ici à ben curtis
delépine cérémonie de commémoration des
20 ans du génocide cette fois autre
exemple de décontextualisation qui vient
lui aussi à ajouter de l'huile sur le
feu assure contexte tendu oui c'est ce
type de publication que l'on découvre
ici cette photo des internautes qui
affirme que deux étudiants venus de
république démocratique du congo ont été
torturés et tués au rwanda alors qu'en
est il une fois de plus c'est la
recherche d'image inversée qui va de
nous permettre d'en connaître un petit
peu plus sur le contexte il y avait
toutefois quelques indices regardez on
va grossir l'une des photos et on a en
filigrane une mention ici c'est le
standaard standaard c'est le nom d'un
journal kenyan et ça nous renvoie cette
recherche d'image inversée évidemment
vers plusieurs tweets vers plusieurs
articles de presse dont celui évidemment
du standard nous sommes au kenya donc
lors du madara cas a day jour de fête
nationale en l'occurrence était le 1er
juin dernier l'homme arrêté en fait
celui qui a fait irruption sur la
pelouse quelques instants avant son
arrestation pour interrompre le discours
du président kenyan uhuru kenyatta vous
avez ici via d'autres médias un autre
angle de la même scène que l'on peut
être découvrir à l'image rien à voir
donc vous l'aurez compris ni avec le
rwanda a ni avec la république
démocratique du congo merci anthony st
léger c'était info ou intox avec anthony
rester avec nous